i'd like to discuss
a drink it's actually a tea that you can
consume
to help you lower blood pressure now of
course you want to find the root cause
whether it's a potassium deficiency or a
vitamin d deficiency or some other root
cause but in the meantime if you want a
great remedy
that has virtually no side effects
this video is for you and the
antioxidants in this tea are actually
stronger than green tea now in the first
study i want to talk about there is
significant blood pressure lowering
effects in both systolic and diastolic
systolic is a top number where you're
measuring the contraction of the heart
and diastolic is the bottom number where
we're measuring pressure with the
relaxation phase and in the study they
found that this tea worked as effective
as the blood pressure medication
captrophil and it has a slight diuretic
effect but that's not the main reason
why it works but it may rid excess
sodium but it doesn't reduce potassium
and they also found some additional
benefits from this tea that it can help
reduce your triglycerides and your ldl
cholesterol not to think that's bad if
you're on the ketogenic diet
but if you're not on the ketogenic diet
and your ldl is high
this tea could be helpful in another
study uh 65 people it was found that
this tea significantly reduced systolic
blood pressure compared to the placebo
and then in a meta-analysis which
they're evaluating a whole bunch of
independent studies the randomized
control trials showed significant
lowering effect in both systolic and
diastolic with
virtually
no
side effects because one of the big side
effects with high blood pressure
medication is something called
drug-induced nutrient depletion so when
you take these drugs that help you lower
blood pressure you end up with a calcium
deficiency a potassium deficiency and a
magnesium deficiency all three minerals
as part of your electrolytes and then
all three mineral deficiencies can then
contribute to having high blood pressure
so it's pretty bad when the side effect
ends up causing the actual problem
you're trying to
treat and then i want to mention another
one that's interesting a randomized
controlled double-blinded clinical trial
where the control was another high blood
pressure medication called lisinopril
now lisinopril actually showed better
results
but not by much the group's blood
pressure started out being 146
over 97 okay and then after the trial
the blood pressure went down to 129
over 85 which is pretty darn good i mean
this demonstrated a 65.15
percent therapeutic benefit by using
this tea compared to lacinopro i mean
that's that's remarkable with
100
safety
zero
side effects so what was this t are you
ready for this hibiscus tea hibiscus is
this beautiful flower that they turn
into tea and the pigments in this flower
are composed of the phytonutrient
anthocyanins and apparently it acts as
an ace inhibitor
and ace is just an enzyme that's
involved in the
fluid balance within your body as well
as the blood pressure system and that's
why a lot of different blood pressure
medications are ace inhibitors so
hibiscus tea
is a natural ace inhibitor and so what
an ace inhibitor does is it lowers the
pressure it relaxes the vascular system
and it's zinc base so ace is an enzyme
and it's composed of zinc and what's
interesting about zinc is that if you
have a zinc deficiency that can
contribute to high blood pressure so
there could be a connection between this
ace inhibitor being formed and zinc not
being available but the point is that
zinc deficiency can increase your blood
pressure and you also have zinc
deficiencies when you have a diabetic
who normally has high blood pressure and
you're also going to see a zinc
deficiency when you have kidney problems
and liver problems and of course with
that you have high blood pressure so the
antioxidants in hibiscus tea
uh are more powerful than green tea
which is fascinating now you don't want
to take this tea if you're on a diuretic
unless you check with your doctor
because
apparently this tea does act like a
diuretic so if you're doing this tea and
your blood pressure is being lowered and
you're also doing a medication you can
end up with even lower blood pressure so
check with your doctor on that hibiscus
tea has some other powerful benefits as
well
there's been some studies that can
inhibit gastric cancer by up to 52
percent it was shown the phytonutrients
in hibiscus tea also have
antimicrobial properties which seems to
be just as effective as certain
antibiotics and even more effective than
penicillin there's also a study that
showed that it can even help you
decrease fat on your liver so if you're
going to drink this hibiscus tea
definitely do it for about six weeks to
see the full effect
but in the meantime you need to also get
your vitamin d levels higher and your
potassium levels higher and for that
information i put a video up right here